i saw brett favre at the seafood
restaurant in our hometown
and it just comes up and you just now
tell us you saw that was he in crocs
i didn't see his feet he had sensitive
gums though
oh wow what a legend he's a louisiana
boy right
i saw brett favre mississippi we used to
go eat mushrooms and kill them we used
to put on
brett favre jerseys me and my black
friend will put on an um
i want to say it was a julius pepper but
it might have been somebody else's
friend put on a reggie white
um no i want to say it with julius
peppers and we would get
mushroomed out and chase each other hell
yeah try and sack your butt
yeah no just like it was nothing sexual
we were just children and he was
straight and i was straight that's fun
times
wow what a good time but that was in
brett favre's hometown dude and then i
saw him walking in the seafood
restaurant i walk
there's like you walk up to walk it's
like has one of those galley gangway
seafood restaurant style you know like
oh walk the plank in you know type of
thing
and off to the left there's a man
sitting there and it looked like brett
favre from the side i only saw about
25 of his face
and i'm walking in and the guy inside
like
knew me and said hey and uh and i said
is that brett favre sitting on the porch
because i used to work there i used to
smoke weed there and work there
and uh and he said yeah that's him is it
joe's crab shack
no it's like called morton's steakhouse
but no see
it's not seafood it's not steaks it's
like water steak seafood
how many shrooms did you eat um
probably 30 grams is that a lot that's
i remember playing against a [ __ ]
nickel defense for about an hour and a
half
so i ate a lot of rooms oh dude we had
as many as you could as the ground would
make
oh my oh so they're fresh off the ground
fresh off the ground
you don't [ __ ] around oh you could smell
the [ __ ] you could smell the steak on
them some of them were medium rare
bro they were fresher than that thing on
your neck boy
were you seeing stuff oh dude yeah it's
all right
he thought i was being chased by reggie
white he was so [ __ ] hot
dude i saw i was playing against jake
deloam for two quarters
i saw a lot wow what a reference i saw a
lot rosie
[Music]
is